[Applause]
harry styles helps make one couple's
dreams come true
by stopping his concert in portugal so a
fan could pull off a surprise proposal
of a lifetime
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
cue the tears with harry watching on
stage the concert goer serenades his
lady with an elvis presley classic and
ultimately she says yes
[Music]
[Applause]
seems like harry's love on tour concerts
are living up to the name and the singer
even gives a sweet blessing before
resuming the show
[Music]
[Applause]
we just love love maybe harry could be
next to pop the question he has been
going strong with olivia wilde that's
right that is right and we're hoping for
lots of cute couple moments when the
don't worry darling press tour kicks off
later this year it's the movie they met
on olivia directed harry stars
our life
together
i could lose this
back in june a source told e.t harry and
olivia are much more comfortable with
the spotlight on their relationship than
they were in the beginning it just makes
me realize how lucky i am
and we're sure olivia's counting her
blessings when it comes to harry our
source says he helped keep her kiddos
otis and daisy whom she shares with ex
jason sudeikis in mind when discussing
taking their romance public quote at
first they were very aware of how others
would perceive their relationship so for
the sake of her kids and jason they
wanted to keep things low profile
and while they might be more comfortable
sharing their love these days our source
says they're not quite ready to let fans
all in on their relationship the one
thing they ask of us is to stay here
where it's safe
yeah our source says the pair is okay
with showing pda but privacy is still
very important to both of them adding
quote they also want to live their lives
authentically and that means some pda
and speaking about each other publicly
maybe while both stars may stay
tight-lipped about their romance the
questions are sure to come but we're
happy to hear they're a united front
quote they're in such a good place and
so confident in their relationship
and when the time comes we just hope the
engagement is as romantic as this one
especially if harry's involved
[Applause]
[Music]
you